well the Trump campaign is forcefully
forcefully rather responding to a sixty
minutes interview with Vice President
Biden where the former vice president
says it's improper for president Trump's
children to have offices in the White
House the candidates spoke with CBS
evening news anchor and managing editor
we know her well nor O'Donnell at his
Delaware home Biden addressed the
president's attacks on his son hunter he
also spoke about the campaign and his
standing as a front-runner let's talk
about the state of the race because it
has tightened do you still consider
yourself the front-runner I know I'm a
front-runner
find me a national poll with a notable a
couple exceptions the last four that
have come out but look this is a
marathon yes this is a marathon you can
look at the last campaign finance filing
we looked at that you have less than
nine million in the bank
Bernie Sanders is thirty four nearly
thirty four million dollars in the bank
senator Warren has 26 million how do you
compete against that I just flat beat
them we're on the course to do extremely
well I'm not I'm not worried about being
able to fund this campaign I really am
not truly and nor O'Donnell's back
welcome back to the table good to be
back guys so what do you think in row
Donald about Sunday well look it's a
pretty stunning interview I mean it's a
wide-ranging interview you hear the vice
president declaring himself the
front-runner in her poll he said he got
into this race because it's a battle for
the soul of the nation but right now
it's a battle for the soul of the
Democratic Party
and Jill Biden proudly declares him a
moderate in this interview and he talks
about Medicare for all he says how about
truth for all you know Biden is
promising steady stable leadership you
have Warren and Sanders promising bold
radical change he's and what's she
waiting in the polls so how is he
competing against Sanders and well he's
actually been consistent in the national
polls what we see though is that he's
not doing as well in Iowa and New
Hampshire people strong in South
Carolina but this is the larger strategy
which is why I asked that question about
fundraising Biden can do well in the
first four states not necessarily have
to win because it's about a hundred and
fifty delegates he has to do well Super
Tuesday Tuesday right which is about
1,400
delegates and so you need the money for
the long haul and that's really where
he's having difficulty how did he
respond to the controversy surrounding
his son Hunter and his business dealings
with Ukraine well that's big part of
this interview as well because that's
also the focus of this impeachment
inquiry right so the Vice former vice
president insists that Hunter did
nothing wrong
absolutely nothing wrong in his view and
then he takes the opportunity to talk
about how he would do his own White
House differently that children will not
serve in the White House he specifically
attacks Jared Kushner the son-in-law of
the vice president when I asked him do
you think he should be negotiating
Middle East peace and he said what
credentials does he bring to that and
interestingly enough as you mentioned
the Trump campaign put out this very
lengthy statement late last night by
their campaign manager defending the
qualifications of Jared Kushner to be
serving in the White House and
negotiating things like Middle East
peace even Ivanka who of course has an
office in the White House as well
children are off-limits but that
certainly change on both sides this time
right absolutely
yeah he's Biden doing things differently
this time he ran back in 1988 he ran in
2008 what she is doing this is his third
run for president I mean think about
that he turns 77 in November he
addresses the issue of age he addresses
the issue of whether he slipped it all
in some of the gaps that he makes in
these debates he says these debates are
a learning curve for him so we'll see a
lot of that I think it's a it's a
wide-ranging interview as I mentioned
confidently he said I am I know I'm the
front yes and he's confident but not
only he will beat his Democratic rivals
but that he will beat Trump like a drum
as something tells me that the White
House will be watching that interview
too on Sunday night no doubt we're good
to see you always always good to have
you here